good afternoon everyone my name is David
Elwood and I want to welcome you to the
Harvard Kennedy School John F Kennedy
jr. forum is a terrifically important
and exciting event at a really critical
time and welcome to the 2015 black
policy conference here at the Kennedy
School this is the 11th anniversary of
the conference and the theme is old to
the struggle new to the movement
strategic action for fighting racial
injustice I'd like to acknowledge our
very distinguished panelists here and
special thanks to the conference chair
co-organizers I think you have no idea
how much time and energy it takes to put
together something like this and in
order to make it easier and more helpful
for them we reschedule exams and other
things during the same time so that that
way they can really really learn from
the experience but I do want to thank
coach here Samantha Jordan Abdul solid
abdul aziz saeed and my Akane so thank
you all
I cannot remember a time in recent
history where the kind of energy and
focus has been more intense on a set of
issues around racial justice obviously
particularly around criminal criminal
justice issues even the events of the
last couple of days once again
reinforcing our fears and so I am
particularly thrilled that this
conference is going on now and that we
have a chance to host it a number of
people this university and the certainly
in this school have been quite intensely
engaged not only in protesting but in
looking for answers and feeding into the
President's Commission on policing in
the 21st century we've had many guest
speakers here but also panels in organ
groups and so forth at the school but
it's not enough and it isn't only that
issue there are so many issues that bro
follow from but and also perceived those
kinds of issues of justice and so forth
much of my life is in study has been
devoted to studying of inequality social
policies and like and this feels like an
incredibly important time when you look
and see not only what's happening again
in the criminal justice realm but on
inequality on schooling on issue after
issue it's a time when I think we almost
feel like we're on a knife edge where if
we don't move soon we may find ourselves
in a place where it's very very hard to
move from so thank you for taking the
time on a friday afternoon to be here
and for the weekend i think it's really
really quite exciting and important it
is my job to introduce Karen Weaver and
that's a particularly joyous job for me
Karen Weaver here is our senior
associate dean for degree programs and
student affairs at HKS also just known
as dean of students I had the great
fortune astonishing fortune to being
able to hire her recently she is a very
distinguished she previously had been
involved in a small University based in
Princeton New Jersey I don't remember
the name of the university itself
but her role here is she oversees the
staff of degree programs student affairs
including admission student financial
services registrar's office student
services career advancement student
diversity inclusion etc etc and one of
the striking thing is besides doing all
those kinds of things to make this
school work for people and try and build
an inclusive place she's also been
deeply engaged in the issues
particularly the issues this year and a
whole variety of other kinds of things
it's not actually very surprising
because that she's involved well outside
the school as well because she has a PhD
in history from Columbia and so she
brings to the table both a great deal of
wisdom and empathy and understanding she
was really reemployed for example to
serve a second term as national series
editor for teaching religious studies
produced by oxford university press
another you known University elsewhere
and she's a clue she was a clue scholar
at Columbia and she received a merit
fellowship and so forth and so on we are
enormously glad and all of us are quite
lucky to have with us Karin Weber Karen
thank you you know actually I'm going to
have you to come back up do you know
would I think the students have a
surprise for you so if you can just come
on up you want to come up on the stage I
think that would be great right there in
the middle you don't mind you know what
I'm gonna turn over to Samantha hi
everyone sorry about that my name is
Samantha Jordan and I'm here with my
co-chairs my Akane and abdullah syed
we're the coaches for the black policy
conference this is actually our 11th
year we began in 2004 which incidentally
was Dina woods first year here at HKS
and we wanted to take some time out to
thank him and recognized him for all the
work he's done to create spaces like
this to talk about difficult policy
issues especially those that impact
communities of color so we have this
plaque you wanted to thank you from the
black policy conference for exceptional
commitment and dedication to HKS
students
I take it back I do like surprises all
right thank you so much let's give dean
Elwood and the students another round of
applause I have the distinct honor
pleasure and privilege of introducing
our panelists this afternoon and I'm
sure you like me are very excited and
very much interested in getting to the
conversation so first I'd like to start
with the formal introductions I think
you know a lot about our panelists but
I'll tell you a little bit more about
their background and what makes them so
wonderful as artists miss Chrisette
Michelle is a Grammy award-winning
singer and songwriter and she reached
recently established her own label rich
hipster she's a native of New York and
her father was a sociologist and her
mother was a psychologist in high school
she led gospel choirs and she completed
her undergraduate studies in vocal
performance miss Michelle uplifts
communities by creating a new lifestyle
soundtrack that focuses on being rich
and heart and art while traveling the
world her mission is to build brand new
nations built on the act of giving peace
and unity along the way she's had
notable hip hop collaborations with
prominent artists such see nas and the
roots and so many others her music has
gone to number one on the Billboard
release and in 2009 she won a grammy
award for best urban alternative
performance for the song be ok featuring
hip-hop singer will.i.am of Black Eyed
Peas when she's not singing she's
supporting charities with her time this
ranges from serving food to displace
families speaking at women's shelters to
visiting schools as a motivational
speaker her heart and next project lies
in opening homes for teenage boys ladies
and gentlemen Grammy Award winner
Chrisette Michelle
our next panelist Clint Smith mr. Smith
is a teacher poet and doctoral candidate
in education here at Harvard University
with the concentration and culture
institutions and society he serves as a
resident teaching artists in Boston
Public Schools and as a writing
instructor at Bay State Correctional
Center in Norfolk Massachusetts
previously he taught high school English
in Prince George's County Maryland and
served as a public health worker in
Soweto South Africa his research
interest include critical pedagogy mass
incarceration the intersection of art
and activism how literacy shapes the
formation of adolescent identity and
youth civic education in 2013 Clint was
named the Christine sarbanes Teacher of
the Year by the Maryland Humanities
Council he has spoken at the US
Department of Education and has been
featured on ted.com additionally he has
been profiled in the book a teacher
heroes in the classroom Clint is a 2014
National Poetry Slam champion an
individual world poetry finalists and
has served as a cultural ambassador for
the u.s. Department of State conducting
international workshops on
cross-cultural understanding and youth
empowerment ladies and gentlemen mr.
Clint Smith
so I have the distinct honor of
moderating our panel this afternoon I
have a series of questions that we've
prepared for our panelists and then at
about four-thirty for 45 or so we're
going to open it up for you to ask
questions to our panelists I'd like to
get started I think it's important to
start our conversation this afternoon by
really explicate encontra steam which is
all to the struggle new to the movement
and I think it's so important to
acknowledge pioneers from the Harlem
Renaissance and the Black Arts Movement
and the embedded social justice
tradition of many black artists from the
nineteenth and twentieth centuries do
each of you see yourselves as an
extension of that movement and tradition
and if so how sure in so many ways I'm
so grateful for those who came before us
and paved the way I think about things
like having an agent and having an agent
who's over 60 or almost 70 years old who
has booked the talents of those who
still had to maybe walk in the side or
not be able to hang out with everybody
else I mean at the end of the day the
people who taught him might be the
people who didn't respect or receive me
so the way that the woman who came
before me carried themselves the way
they treated others is really really
important and I think it attributes to
just hug your character your demeanor
and and what you give them paves the way
for us that makes any sense yeah yeah
that's a great question i want to think
about it i think of how i almost go back
to the founding of this country and how
black people were brought to the United
States and and never with the intention
of being able to read write or create
and I keep coming back to this text I
read from Thomas Jefferson notes on the
state of Virginia which is his memoir
and in it he says explicitly that black
people are inherently inferior to white
people he says that the slave is
incapable
a possessing and sustaining complex
emotion complex thought the slave is
incapable of love and and so what does
that mean you know for the intellectual
founding father of this country the
person who is largely responsible for
the conception of the Declaration of
Independence in the Constitution to like
have not thought that that I was fully
human that we were fully human to not
think that I could love my family that I
could have passion that I could love art
that I could create art and so when I
think about what it means to be
specifically a black artist now I think
we come from a tradition of people who
have resisted that since we came here
who have resisted this idea that we
weren't to make weren't meant to make
beautiful things and weren't meant to to
create things that spoke to the the
specificity specificity and sort of
idiosyncrasies of our lives and so I've
been resting a lot myself this year with
like what it means to be to create
political art and you know and that
doesn't in political art you know I
think when I first started doing poetry
I thought it meant that every poem had
to be indignant I thought it meant that
I had to be about the man blue white
supremacy like I thought it had to be
that sort of thing but but in thinking
about that I realized that you know to
come from from an ancestry in the
tradition of people who weren't meant to
create and to create at all isn't of
itself like a political act and in and
of itself is an act of revolution right
in pushing back against this thing we
were never meant to do and so whether
you're writing about Ferguson or whether
you're writing about a flower those
things like in and of themselves
represent something really powerful and
something that you know speaks to to
what we've decided to do in the face of
a history that has been very violent
towards us absolutely and as d know what
said particularly with my background as
a historian I'm ever mindful of history
and the arts in the intersection and
just how much courage and vision it
takes to be an artist and how it really
challenges the very historical concepts
of people of African descent not being
fully human so thank you both for both
oh sure make
a point because i love what you said
about it may not necessarily be a
specific lyric at the end of the day too
there are so many ways to support our
community by where we showcase our art
you know and so you might have your
flower in a black-owned gallery and
create traffic there you might hire
perhaps a black promoter to promote your
shows I know agencies huge agencies and
they're only really four of them in
America that will not take phone calls
from us and so when we take our own
phone calls from each other when we
support our own businesses sometimes
that's making a statement and saying
this Grammy award-winning artist is
performing here tonight and mrs. who
hired her this is who brought the chairs
to the venue this assume was the cleanup
crew and when we stand up for each other
I think we make a statement and say we
are just as great as so it's it's
artistic but it's also economic
political and social is absolutely and I
want to keep going with this theme on on
one hand music poetry and the visual
arts have an aesthetic value there's
there's beauty there's something that
you appreciate about what's created but
on another level there is the power of
the message that is conveyed in the
piece or in the artistic rendering and I
want to know how do you see yourselves
fitting within this larger trajectory of
conscious artists and who are some of
the artists who have influenced you
Queen Latifah somebody who I think is I
mean you know I mean you NIT why was the
big record I'm gonna be all SAT around
on our living rooms with leggings on and
big top hats like she had on and saying
you and ity and I was a moment because
she was in the midst of so many other
things going on and to sing a song
unity as so she was somebody who
definitely influenced me do I think that
I make a similar contribution I'm
thinking about Queen Latifah today and
the movies that she's on today like
hairspray the move the places that you
find her on HBO now she's coming out
with so for me it's really about where
she puts herself where she allows
herself to be seen that says a lot about
how valuable she thinks her art is and
who she thinks should see it who she
thinks should pay for it mmm interesting
yes yeah I always come back to James
Baldwin I mean Baldwin is in many ways
kind of like if I have any sort of
problem in life like if you know I'm
struggling with issues of systemic
oppression or if my tooth hurts I'm like
I just need a recent James Baldwin
everything will be okay Jimmy will tell
me what to do no but I just think he
wrote so prolifically in such a
remarkable way and then the fact that he
wasn't traditionally educated and a lot
of what this year has been for me and
you mentioned in my biography i've been
working at a correctional center in
North Massachusetts a lot of what the
reading James Baldwin and working at
that Center have been lists with a
decoupling of what it means to be well
school as compared to well educated
right and you know we sit in this place
that represents you know something very
powerful sort of the intellectual
bastion of this country and maybe the
world but but I think it's so important
for us and for myself to remind myself
that that there exists an entire world
of folks beyond this institution and
beyond the Academy who bring a rich sort
of like intellectual conscious political
disposition to a lot of these issues
were talking about and I've been I was
recently thinking about the word
conscious is interesting because i think
it denotes a sort of like intentionality
and i was thinking about to your point
this idea of artists having access we're
not having access to
spaces and so in my context i'm thinking
about the literary world and i'm
thinking about growing up and how few
authors there were who looked like me
how few authors there were who talked
about my life as i experienced it and so
for me I was I was really disillusioned
with reading and school as a kid until I
came across Walter Dean Myers and his
work and for folks who who aren't
familiar Walter Dean Myers is like an
incredible african-american young adult
fiction writer and just wrote series in
series of books about with young black
male protagonists and it was really the
first time that I had the opportunity to
like see myself in in books and you know
see myself and kids who looked like me
living on the page and that was powerful
and so what Walter Dean Myers considered
himself a conscious rather than I don't
know but I think he wrote purposely and
I think he wrote for for a group of
young people who who had largely been
left out of the literary canon and for
me that's I try to take a similar
approach you know I don't know if I
consider my self conscious as much as I
I just try to be honest you know you
know the conscious versus honest I don't
go there but I really yeah because do
they go hand in hand are you doing your
duty if you're not both I mean what you
know when when those two things have
diverse each other then how much of our
there are we being you know and such as
such a tough call because you're an
artist first of all you don't want to
offend anybody to you want to be able to
speak to everyone and then to you want
to get something off of your chest that
really means something to you so so the
consciousness artistic there's
kind of a fluidity right there's got to
be in that the art of being an artist
yeah certainly I think that I guess
sometimes I worry that with the term
conscious it can become sort of
restraining and that it limits one's
ability to speak to like the totality of
an experience right so when when Talib
Kweli or common are most def you know
who were rappers that I looked up to
growing up and like very much you know
they saved my life in many ways you know
whenever they were labeled the conscious
rappers and so whenever they talked
about something that wasn't injustice
this directly everybody was very
disillusioned and they were like oh my
gosh like I can't believe common is
talking about like you know going to a
party that's crazy like one but it's
like no he's a person you know and like
he wants to have a good time and like
and he wants to like fight oppression
and turn up like in that's that's okay
and so so I think it I stay honest
because he I want folks who are honest
about like their whole experience in
their home life at that point that's
great well I want to transition to
something a little more serious only
because I was thinking about how the
students earlier acknowledged Dean
Elwood and his tenure here is a Dean and
one of the things he did earlier this
year was to host a town hall meeting
that he and I co moderated in order to
have a community-wide conversation about
what happened in Ferguson with Michael
Brown and staten island with Eric garner
and many of you may also be aware of the
recent killing of Walter Scott in South
Carolina and I just wanted to know what
were your what are your personal
reactions to what happened and do you
think artists have a responsibility to
address big issues like listen the
second part goes back to one of the
points that you raised earlier about how
do you create an inclusive conversation
or dialogue and not alienate some of
your fans so I'm really interested in
that
point so I recently had the incredible
opportunity to present at the ted
conference in vancouver british columbia
and I remember I got the email and they
were like Clint we would love for you to
come perform at Ted and we're hoping
that it can be something positive and
uplifting and I was like hmm okay and
this was right after Tamir rice had been
killed so that was on my heart in mind a
lot and so you know i was in sort of an
emotional space and i responded i was
like Hello thank you so much for the
opportunity I plan on talking about how
white parents have to raise their or how
black parents have to raise their
children and categorically different
ways that white parents just to keep
them a lot of thanks and I didn't hear
back from them for like three weeks I
was like oh i guess i'm not speaking at
Ted anymore but then they responded and
they were like well we hope it can end
with hope and reserve I was like I a
middle ground but but I when I knew I
was going to this place that represented
almost like a different stratosphere of
like power and wealth I mean it's a
crazy place like Al Gore is like
chilling at the salad bar Bill Gates is
walking around in a bowl of soup it's
like a very bizarre remarkable place and
but I wanted to make sure that I was
bringing work that was going to push
that audience in a way that I wasn't
sure they otherwise would be so a lot of
what I thought about and continue to
think about is how can I create work
that is unsettling because so many of
these are unsettling issues without
making it so uncomfortable that people
to now because I think so often what
happens especially you know in the
progressive community is that folks can
make people feel like personally
implicated and that's not to say people
shouldn't because a lot of times folks
are complicit in in what's happening
around them but i think if if somebody
feels like you're calling them a racist
before you ever have the opportunity to
like meaningfully engage them I don't
think that's productive at all and so a
lot of that I think comes from speaking
from a specific vantage point right and
so when I went I did a piece that spoke
about what it was like having
growing up in a world where like my
parents had to make make decisions
between whether or not to let me be like
a child in all of that that represents
as compared to like trying to keep me
safe thank you me love yeah I understand
that I'm some people's voice it was
always comfortable saying that but if
someone keeps telling me something just
get over it and deal with it essentially
I'll come out with an album and it'll be
an album where it was scientifically
created to be played on the radio and it
will be played on the radio and there'll
be a top-10 song on there and people may
or may not purchase it but usually they
will then I come out with the album
called let freedom reign and I called a
lyric that is that goes I'm not
afro-american I'm just black in America
just a passive American making believe
I'm better than what we've been and and
I get deep and I say what I really
wanted to say on the first one and not
as many people buy that record right but
maybe half as many and then I'll come
back out with another one where it's
scientifically created to be played on
the radio and having that balance of art
is kind of what makes me feel like I'm
being honest and conscious of it because
it is an exhausting endeavor to not be
both I mean at the end of the day some
days you want to sing about love some
days you really really really want to
light the fire underneath somebody took
us and tell me what you really think
about society but you don't want to say
goodbye to everybody by doing so and so
it is a tough a tough call but I think
you go back and forth a little bit and
one of the things that I wanted you both
to address most of the people here in
the audience are many of the people here
in the audience or tuning in our
students what advice do you have for
aspiring artists who are trying to make
a change in society but who are also
trying to make a living whether it's
paying for groceries are paying for
graduate school or place to live just to
sustain themselves what advice do you
have for them yeah I mean there's
there's so many marketing is one
my favorite subjects right because we
have this thing called social media
where there's everything from meerkats
and facebook to snapchat to Twitter to
Instagram etc so we're talking about
budgets and we're looking for free
marketing you're trying to have a voice
in society and you want to say something
that's meaningful but you don't know if
it'll pay the bills right dress it up a
little bit put a nice graphic on it
people are are attracted to what looks
nice and unfortunately sometimes you
have to get somebody by putting your
hair up in a ponytail and slap it on
some red lipstick putting it on on on
Instagram and then having the quote of
the day underneath that's really
touching it's really really hard again
to balance those two things but we have
social media which makes things a little
less expensive and then mixing up the
visual to attract and then the conscious
to educate yeah yeah no I think that
points really well founded I think
social media has very much democratized
who can create art and who has access to
art and we don't have to go through
traditional large corporations and
entities to to disseminate our message
like for me all of you know I have no
agency or anything like that I just put
some videos on YouTube and you know it I
was fortunate enough to that thing's
kind of kind of happen from there so I
think being purposeful I think you know
establishing partnerships with people
who can who can disseminate your message
whatever it may be in in the best
possible way but i but i think even
before that what I I taught high school
English for several years and so you
know I had a lot of kids who want it to
be you know singers or rappers or
dancers and and and I think we want them
to have those dreams right I think
that's important but sometimes I feel
like folks get more caught up in trying
in the hustle to disseminate their
message than the hustle of trying to
refine
aircraft right and like you want to be
the best writer or the best poet or the
best singer or the best dancer you can
be so that once you are in you know once
you you have been disseminated you you
have something really powerful and
really different and really unique to
you to bring so I think you know making
sure that you focus on on the art before
you focus on how the art is is going to
be conveyed to the world so I have one
more burning question and this is before
we open the floor up to questions I
think many of your fans would like to
know this question is question as well
what would you describe as some of the
most powerful and/or prolific words or
lyrics from your body of work and would
you be willing to share that with our
audience this evening oh man I think
they ask me you sing sorry they're
asking you to sing no I don't think
that's it is that what you could say
whatever you feel led to do
unfortunately I was wrapping this part
okay okay so very unfortunate right but
if I can give us a tiny explanation I
was so uncomfortable with singing love
songs and breakup songs and I just felt
like I had so much to say and I was
disappointed with a lot of things that
were going on in our community and I
told my mom said mom I'm gonna put our
little in Turtles you know change the
world kind of records you know let's see
what happens and the record label said
well this is going to be called an art
piece I said all right they said it's
not going to be commercial I said well
well that's fine I'll you know I'll deal
with that I didn't realize how many
people will recall this lyric but it is
I'm not afro-american I'm just black in
America just the passive American making
believe I'm better than what we've been
and at the end of the day
it's about can I get my self-esteem to
meet what they are telling me freedom is
you know can I get my self-esteem to
meet what they're telling me I have so
that i can let go of the titles that
I've been given and create from a space
of peace with who I am and freedom and
that's a tough thing to do when you know
where you came from and it kind of lives
with you on a daily basis so you know we
always in the hip-hop community of
what's afro-american you know what
exactly is that and there's all these
incredible definitions but really I
think maybe I might be an American with
brown skin and that's uncomfortable to
say in front of people but is what I
thought so that was the lyric yeah thank
you thank you thank you thank you um
yeah I think I'm gonna actually do a
part of a poem from what I did for my my
TED talk um you know I'll do it sitting
do my feel like my grandpa one night
when I was 12 years old on an overnight
field trip to another city my friends
and I bought super soakers and turn the
hotel parking lot into our own water
filled battle zone we hid behind cars
running through the darkness that lay
between the street lights boundless
laughter ubiquitous across the pavement
but within 10 minutes my father came
outside grabbed me by my forearm and led
me into our room with an unfamiliar grip
before I could say anything tell him how
foolish it made me look in front of my
friends he derided me for being so naive
looked me in the eye fear consuming his
face and said son I'm sorry but you
can't act the same as your white friends
you can't pretend to shoot guns you
can't run around in the dark you can't
hide behind anything other than your own
teeth I know now how scared he must have
been
how easily I could have fallen into the
empty of the night that some man will
mistake this water for a good reason to
wash all of this away these are the
sorts of messages I've been inundated
with my entire life I always keep your
hands where they can see them don't move
too quickly take off your hood when the
Sun Goes Down my parents raised me and
my siblings in an armored of advice an
ocean of alarm bells or someone wouldn't
steal the breath from our lungs so that
they wouldn't make a memory of this skin
that we could be kids not casket or
concrete and it's not because they
thought it would make us better than
anyone else it's simply because they
wanted to keep us alive all of my black
friends were raised with the same
message the talk given to us when we
became old enough to be mistaken for a
nail ready to be hammered to the ground
when people made our melanin synonymous
with something to be feared but what
does it do to a child to grow up knowing
that you cannot simply be a child that
the whims of adolescents are too
dangerous for your breath that you
cannot simply be curious you are not
afforded the luxury of making a mistake
that someone's implicit bias might be
the reason you don't wake up in the
morning but this cannot be what defines
us because we had parents who raised us
to understand that our bodies weren't
meant for the backside of a bullet but
for flying kites and jumping rope and
laughing until our stomachs first we had
teachers who taught us how to raise our
hands in class and not just the signal
surrender and that the only thing we
should give up the idea that we aren't
worthy of this world so when we say that
black lives matter it's not because
others don't it's simply because we must
affirm that we are worthy of existing
without fear when there are so many
things that tell us we are not I want to
live in a world where my son will not be
presumed guilty the moment he is born
where a toy in his hand isn't mistaken
for anything other than a toy and I
refused to accept that we can't build
this world into something new some place
where a child's name doesn't have to be
written on a t-shirt or a tombstone
where the value of someone's life isn't
determined by anything other than the
fact that they had lungs a place where
every single one of us can breathe
thank you both so much and now we're
ready to hear questions from you and I'd
like to invite you to come we have four
microphones to hear on the lower level
and two in the balcony all questioners
we just ask for you to identify yourself
and remember a question no speeches and
if you can in your question with a
question mark that would be great so if
you could come now and present your
questions to our illustrious panelists
we're going to start right here if you
could say your name hi my name is
Genesis Fonseca and on the first year
PhD candidate in American Studies my
question is actually for you Clint I was
wondering if you could share with us a
little bit more about the black poet
speak out movement online i think it's
it's important for people in this
audience to know about that thank you so
the the phenomenon that genesis is
referencing black poet speak out was
started by a group of black poets from
the kavik condom collective which is
this artist black artists retreat based
out of university of pittsburgh and they
came together after Michael Brown Eric
Gardner and a lot of these killings and
non indictments and came together and
say what is the black artists
responsibility specifically the black
poets responsibility in this space and
they kind of created a database for all
of us to come together and put up these
YouTube videos that were poems
specifically delineating the sort of
nuances in idiosyncrasies of black life
as it relates to state-sanctioned
violence and even beyond
state-sanctioned violence because of
that we part of the point of that
movement was to ensure that we weren't
being defined by these things that were
destroying us or that were trying to
destroy us and that the what black life
represents is so much more than this
perpetual inundation of violence that
were subjected to and that we see and
something I've been thinking things a
lot about because you know with the man
who was killed in South Carolina Walter
Scott you know my 24 hours my facebook
feed was was all videos of this black
man
shot and I'm thinking like what sort of
trauma does that exact on people to
perpetually watch black people being
killed on an ongoing ever-present basis
and certainly it's important because it
brings forth attention and critical
awareness in a way that maybe wasn't
didn't exist before not that these
killings didn't exist before because
they did stop now that cell phones are
more ubiquitous people can can catch
them work or capture them rather but and
I think black black post speak out is is
similar in that like we have this
opportunity and we have this opportunity
to use art to push back against that
being the sort of the singular image of
what blackness is and showing that black
people again what can create in the face
of a violent history and a violent
reality that we kind of live in right
now yeah thank you so yeah you guys can
find it on Facebook just hashtag black
poet speak out and it's a really
beautiful space for of empowerment pain
and empowerment um but also just
consciousness thank you thank you clean
thank you our next question right here
when I write I love it that was getting
too much into my shirt my name is
JaMarcus and a song from arkansas and i
went to college in california and uh now
i'm working here and i noticed that the
black experience in the united states is
similar but there's like subtle
idiosyncrasies relative to what
geographic region that you're in and so
my question is kind of lonely lives of
when you formulate whatever type of
lyrics or any type of dawson's you're
going to express how do you try to make
sure that their representative of the
experiences that all people are black
people in the US face but also that it
they're also make sure that it's not too
general to where they can just be
applied to anyone so I'm just trying to
make sure that you you can speak to
everyone at the same time but also make
sure you're you're hitting people with
relative to what they actually
experienced them with relative to what
they live yep up being politically
correct is not my forte and I don't
try to make it my forte sometimes I'll
say one thing in Detroit Michigan that I
won't say in Connecticut and I might say
something in New Orleans that I might
not say in Los Angeles California I
might even create something on Instagram
and or whatever a social media platform
and only say it when I visit that city
and title it to that city I might only
visit sir I might only put a song on
certain radio stations in certain cities
so I am pretty conscious of who I'm
speaking to and I'm okay with you know
veering on the line of perhaps somebody
in Los Angeles hearing something I said
in San Francisco yeah I think I'm like
very clear that I don't speak for the
whole black experience and I never try
to write in a way there's like this is
what all black people think right I've
been in enough classrooms when I'm where
where I was like the black boys you know
we're reading Toni Morrison the black
perspective were reading Toni Morrison
people lean over like Clint what is Tony
mean like what do the black people think
and I was just like so you know we're
not a homogenous community is intended
to like we are a very diverse group of
folks within this demographic and in it
would be disingenuous and in problematic
if I were to try and write from a
perspective that wasn't my own right and
so and again that's part of being honest
right and like I'm honest about my own
positionality I recognize that like my
black experience is different than your
black experience and different than
everyone in this is on all of our
experiences are unique and different but
I think there's sort of underlying
automatic you know underpinnings that
exist across the experience and even if
someone does so when you know I when I
did that poem at the ted conference they
were very few black people at Ted but
there were people who came up to me
afterwards and said I never realized it
was like that like I can't imagine
having that conversation with my son I'm
so sorry
and for me that it's because I spoke
from from my own life right I didn't try
to say like this is what all black
people experience I said this is
something my dad had to tell me like
every day growing up and and that is my
reality and if it's someone else's
reality that's great but it's important
for you to understand that I'm only
speaking for myself and and it could it
may be reflective of a larger phenomenon
but that's that's not for me to decide
thank you yes right here thank you this
is wonderful my name is Craig Kelly I'm
a mid-career here and I think that a lot
of us have both to learn stuff and to
unlearn stuff we think we know and how
do you as artists combine the teaching
of new things and helping people unlearn
the stuff that they learned long ago
that they would like to jettison but
have difficulty doing I love to make
sure that i'm sorry but marketing its
again you know making sure that young
people are in the same room with old
people in a non-intimidating environment
kind of like this room this is an
incredible space where it we're up in it
but yeah I think that I think it's about
just making sure that you can be that
way that we can be let our hair down and
love on each other and a
non-intimidating environment and then
open up the discussion where it doesn't
feel threatening ya know I think that's
a great question i think it's something
that you know we we've obviously been
wrestling with with here you all-in
wrestling with it at the Kennedy School
we've been wrestling with it at school
like how do you create spaces for people
to engage in these conversations being
cognizant of of biases and preconceived
notions and prejudices that people are
bringing to that space and it's hard
right it's hard because it is I own deep
believer that is never the
responsibility of an oppressed group of
people to convince the oppressed
oppressor so to speak that they are
human right or that they are worthy of
of existing in in just a normal human
way I don't think it's the
responsibility of queer people to do
that on things to the responsibility of
black people of immigrants of poor
people with that said I think that
someone from that group can make a
decision as to whether or not they want
to engage it's not and i think the the
specific thing is about around the world
responsibility so while it's not
someone's responsibility i think that
someone can make a decision that like I
want to engage this person who is
different from me who may have views
that I deem is problematic but I'm going
to meet them where they are and we are
going to engage in a dialogue and
conversation moving forward from there
but I think it's important for for those
who are coming from the majority never
to impose that responsibility on someone
else instead to have that be offered to
them instead of saying like oh well I
don't understand this tell me waiting
for for that person to say like this is
something because that's a traumatic
thing right to have to like delineate
your your entire life of trauma and
violence and that's that's exactly Don
you in both a macro and micro away and
that's a decision that some
has to make I think very much for
themselves last question wow I'm so
lucky thank you so much for being here I
actually my quest my name is Joelle I'm
a first year MPP student here and my
question I think follows quite well with
the other one I guess going beyond
creating spaces to talk about these
issues I wanted to ask what has been
your experience as an artist taking your
art from personal expression to the
point where it is actively involved in
inciting a movement or joining a
movement or getting people to change
their behavior and I ask this in the
context of those of us who are
interested in art who want to use it for
as a tool but right now it's stuck in
that place of just personal expression I
mean there's so many different kinds of
platforms again and we live in a world
where I mean the freedom in that way is
awarded us greatly from social media to
schools there are so many places to
begin expression I've been having a lot
of fun with something called the pose in
post symposium and it might sound you
know fun and silly but essentially it's
a group of girls who decided let's get
each other together in room and share
how we you know create our art and how
we market it in and put it out there for
the world to see you can start your own
little groups you can start your own
things and we live in a world where at
word of mouth and social media spread
really quickly but it's really about
joining forces with the artist next to
you and saying come on let's do this
together and that's what makes it fun
and that's what makes it spread does
that mean you gonna put me on a track I
would love to
I think that's right and that's the
reason that's the reason why i choose my
feature so carefully that's the reason
why i have a feature with rick ross &
talib kweli do you know what I mean
that's how we do it yeah that's happy
chillin what can I say you both have
been fantastic ladies and gentlemen
Chrisette Michele clin Smith please join
me in thanking fans